okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Joanna Garcia
Swisher AKA Maddie from sweet Magnolia
is the new season is on Netflix Thursday
Joanna how you doing today I'm good how
are you I'm doing great I'm really
excited to talk to you I'm excited the
show is coming back and when I'm
wondering being that this is the third
season
for you as an actress on the show do you
have to go back and recap season one and
two like do you re-watch do you watch
any Recaps how do you prep for that
um well you know it's
it's I think
a little bit of all of that I mean I I
definitely think so much has happened
for Maddie in the first couple of
Seasons so as we were entering season
three
um we were also entering on a
cliffhanger again
um
where you know the last thing you see is
Cal knocking this guy out and the cops
are taking him away and so you know just
like season one going into season two
I'm just kind of a hot mess to begin
with
um but there's this season was a real
journey in a lot of ways I feel like
more happened
this season than in any other season oh
wow yeah I feel like
this I was looking at the trailer and I
sent this to our producers I was like my
husband because he doesn't he doesn't
like spoilers
um and hell like no here and there when
he hears things or whatever but for the
most part he doesn't really know what's
going on he's like so much happens this
season and I was like this shows one
percent this trailer hints at one
percent of what happens this season so
it was a doozy oh that's really exciting
to hear and the fans are gonna love to
hear that so you were mentioning too
like where the show leaves off and these
like big moments in the end of each
season
for you though where it is right now
before season three is there anything
about Maddie in particular you think she
needs to change or work on upcoming for
season three
well I think that
is
keenly aware
that are
got that spidey sense that there's some
issues that that she's gonna need to
deal with I mean you've got a lot going
on with her children
um
there is just
you know her so her original marriage
and her family and then you have this
relationship with Cal that is clearly
has a lot of you know things to deal
with and
um so I I feel like
now more than ever
um Maddie's like this might be the
biggest hard-hitting season for her in
terms of like
even though it was a big one in season
one when her husband's left her and
knocked up his mistress and all of those
things it seems crazy but this is this
is the when the rubber hits the road for
Maddie interesting and all these like
interesting things happen around Maddie
and with Maddie so with the character
though that you've got to know really
well now is what is like to you the most
absolute similar trait that Maddie and
Joanna share
that's one thing both just like doers
and we're both just like let's get her
done and we are everything's gonna be
okay and I need to make sure everyone's
okay and so I mean you might describe
that as like type a kind of controlling
um
Maddie learned a lot this season and so
did Joe
um no I I do think that there is a level
of
um
being a Survivor and not meddling like
not and sticking in the mud for two
terribly long
she's very solution based but that comes
with
you know that's probably a
characteristic that's like kind of
annoying and
um and also not totally healthy
um and something I always have to remind
myself of is like it's okay to you know
sit in their muck a little bit yeah I
know that that's a great tip and lesson
right there too and you could you also
mentioned that your husband doesn't like
the spoilers so when the show the new
season comes out do you guys have like a
family ritual do you all watch it
together can you watch yourself like
that or do you just have him watch
separately yeah no I can I love this
show
um
so I've gotten to see it now and so
he's watched a little bit of it he does
watch a lot he does tend to watch on his
own a lot too but the fir we watched the
first episode of the Season together
because he was obviously aware of the
cow being arrested of it all and he was
like I need to know what happens
um
and I think it's like really fun I mean
he knows how much how invested I am in
this show not that I'm not invested in
all of my work but
um this show means a lot to me for a
million reasons and um I love doing it
and I love the people that I get to work
with and I love the story and it's just
really like important to me and so um
and I'm really proud of it and so I'm
along for the ride on the show as well
that's great to hear and that you love
the show yourself too that just gives
excitement for the product for just
everyone who invests their time in this
and
I wonder too fans love to know this now
but do you ever you know peek at the
sweet Magnolias Reddit do you ever visit
there no no way I don't I mean and
listen it's purely because I can't
handle it
um if you wanted to give me like the
positive stuff I'm all for it um oh good
if you not want to know like anything
evil I literally am like there's too
much of that crap out there but I I love
like conspiracy theories I love like you
know those kind of like that kind of
fandom I'm very interested in so if you
want to share that kind of stuff I'm in
for it okay that's cool and that's smart
you're being smart doing that
um also too you've been acting for a
long time so is there anything from when
you first started out to now on a set
like sweet Magnolia's that you've
noticed like is a big difference that
you like to see and how things operate
you know I always have said you things
start at the top and we have incredible
producers
um Cheryl Anderson is a genius and
um
so I just like to that I get to act out
what's in her brain
um I just really enjoy it so it's just
been an incredible
ride and I feel like even
you know the show's been around we
started shooting the show Midway through
2019. and so we it's been a part of our
lives for a really long time and there's
a lot of gaps between seasons and with
the pandemic and things have kind of
like
we should be on the fifth season by now
without this amount of time and so
but I still feel like I'm super
connected to it super invested in it and
I just think that there's still stories
that need to be told and that I'm
excited to dive into and I'm just really
still like my heart I'm still in love
with the show yeah no and what I love
too about your presence on the shows not
only that but it's cool that you're also
in the same area Netflix you're on the
ultimatum queer love you're the host
which is really exciting so people don't
know that you can watch it while you
wait for season three to drop yes but is
hosting something you want more to do
and is there anything in particularly
loved about doing it
um so the answer to that is yes if it
were something that I felt as excited
about as I did hosting ultimatum queer
love
um I was so proud to be a part of the
show I was
um
it was a journey it's a journey for me
uh there's
there's not enough of this type of
Storytelling in my opinion on
um on the airwaves and I think that that
was really compelling and um I thought
the cast was incredibly generous and I
learned a lot I was hosting for the
first time they were all on reality show
for the first time we were all kind of
in it together
um you know it wasn't without
some you know tense moments the
reactions that I got some of the
feedback you know from certain people
which is why I don't read Reddit or
anything like that because it's like you
know why why is she there why you know
why don't you have a queer host doing
this or whatever
I just it's funny because I never really
thought about the why I why wouldn't I
be there from the very beginning I was
asked to do the show and I was like yes
if there's a show that I would do this
type of work for and and guide through
this process and do this for the first
time and kind of get out of my comfort
zone it would it would have to be a show
that I was really excited and passionate
about and
um and so I was really happy to be a
part of it and grateful for the
opportunity I hope they continue to do
the show I don't know
um what the future holds for for this
particular
um franchise of or this particular
ultimatum queer love but I hope that
they continue to tell the story and I
was really proud to be a part of it and
what I host again sure absolutely if it
was something that I felt this excited
about as as doing the ultimatum oh no
that's great to hear and that's what
people really want to see too is see you
host something again because you were so
good at it and they oh yeah no totally
and also I I've been dynastious before I
let you go because you brought up your
husband Swisher huge baseball fan I want
to know though are you a fan of the
pitch clock
the pitch clock stresses me out
tremendously I
I'm like a very I like I'm like kind of
like
I like the certainty surrounding it so
at the beginning of the Season or no the
beginning of Spring training when it was
like oh like yeah the game ended on a
strikeout because of the pitch clock or
whatever I don't even know what it was
but I was like what the heck what
um but I think it's it it seems to be
working and it seems to be speeding up
the games along with a lot of other
things that they've implemented and I'm
certainly no expert but um I think I
think I would have to say sure sure yes
clock I love it so just carrying a shirt
I'm happy it's not okay all right great
done you're hoping to do it good
um Everybody watch you want to kill it
in sweet Magnolia season three on
Netflix Thursday Joanna thank you so
much for joining me I hope to talk to
you in a few it was great talking to you
thanks so much